foreign
what job did you expect to have as a 30
year old writer teacher I asked this
question to colleagues but for more than
20 years that question has also been
asked to millions of teenagers worldwide
what job do you expect to be doing at
30. lawyer journalists managing like a
production company this question is
important because over time it can tell
us how a generation of young people
thinks about the future
so how do actual 15 year olds answer
let's find out
[Music]
this visualization shows all the jobs 15
year olds listed in the year 2000.
the top job was medical doctor but
there's also athlete decorator military
officer
way lower on the list there are jobs
like pharmacist and real estate agent
there are so many jobs listed that
researchers tried to simplify it by
clustering the jobs into even broader
categories here's the top 10 lists for
girls
nearly half of all kids expected to do
the same 10 jobs
that was more than 20 years ago so these
kids are now in their mid-30s did their
expectations come true not really for
example about 11 of girls and about five
percent of boys expect it to be doctors
but these days less than 0.5 percent of
working age people in the countries
where they did this survey are actually
doctors
in 2018 this question was asked again to
15 year olds and this time to a much
bigger group
again the top answer is for doctor
lawyer
athlete
and there were a bunch of other
interesting jobs too
when researchers simplify this list half
of all kids expected to do the same 10
jobs again
but from 2000 to 2018 one thing did
change
in 2000 a portion of kids didn't
actually name a job about 14 percent
in 2018 that group jumped to 25 percent
here's why that's a problem
there's a great piece of research that
tracked thousands of eighth graders
starting in 1988. they specifically
focus on kids who had science-related
Ambitions but were just average in math
they compared that group to kids who had
no science-related Ambitions but they
were high achieving in math
turns out the kids with science-related
ambitions were far more likely to get a
science or engineering degree even
though they weren't as good at math
what this study showed was that ambition
even at an early age plays a huge part
in people's professional outcomes
part of why it's so important is that it
helps them plan for the future
for example if they expect to have a job
that requires a college degree then they
should make plans to go to college
for that reason the Pisa survey also
asks if kids expect to attend college
and it found something interesting among
the kids who expect to have a job that
requires a college degree
one in five had no plans to attend
college which means they probably won't
be doing the job they expect to do
when teens expect to have a certain job
but they don't plan on getting the
required education or experience
researchers who study career paths call
that misalignment
one study of Australian teenagers found
that kids who are misaligned at 15 were
twice as likely to be unemployed or not
in school at age 25.
another study tracked American 15 year
olds they found that the students who
were aligned or over aligned which means
they plan to get more than enough
education for their expected job these
kids had higher wages throughout their
career compared to misaligned kids
but researchers who study these career
Pathways have a pretty good idea of
things we can do to help students think
more clearly about their future
for one young people need to explore
various careers Maybe by visiting
workplaces and it's useful if they've
experienced the workplace by working
part-time or volunteering
those experiences should help them think
about what job they expect to do and
make plans accordingly but most students
don't get these opportunities
only about 40 percent of students in
this survey said they participated in
job shadowing or worksite visits and a
similar percentage of kids so they
participated in job fairs
in other words 15 year olds aren't
getting the support they need to answer
this question
when we don't do the work of helping
kids think through their Futures it's
disadvantaged kids who suffer the most
among the most affluent kids only about
1 in 10 are misaligned but among the
poorest kids about one in three are
misaligned so we entrench the inequality
that already exists
this is every kid who answered the
survey in 2018. the researchers also
looked at which of these jobs are at
risk of automation it turns out about 40
percent of 15 year olds expect to do a
job at risk of Automation in their
country
when you were 15 what did you expect you
would grow up to be
it gets at this profound question of who
you expect to be and what you expect the
world to look like
maybe it's not fair to ask 15 year olds
this question
but fair or not these surveys tell us
they need more help coming up with their
answers
[Music]
foreign